Okay, here's my answer. All we had is, is a simple
change. We just changed that function, instead of using hashlib md5,
to now use hmac, and pass in our secret, plus our
string s, and return the hexdigest of that. Now, this is
actually quite a bit more secure. So, as long as we
have a secret that nobody knows, and normally this would be
a long string of random characters that you generate and probably
store somewhere else in some other module, even if the attacker knows
our algorithm or, you know, watched this, this lesson
as long as he doesn't know what the value
of secret is, he can't produce fake values. Let's
go ahead and give this a test. We're going to say,
print make_secure_val test. We'll give this a run. And
we see output, our value plus our hash. And let's,
let's make sure this works properly, so we'll send
it to a variable and we'll say, print check_secure_val x.
So we take what we outputted here and run it
back into our function, and we see that we get
our result. And if we're to modify x somehow, add
some junk to the end of that string, we get
back nothing. So, with just a quick a quick simple
change, we add, introduce this notion of a secret. Now
somebody who knows our algorithm still can't make fake values.
So let's go ahead and try this out in practice.